it's time to meet another do-gooder or
drew gutter
as we like to call them around here
according to the national restaurant
association over a hundred thousand
restaurants
have closed across the country since the
beginning of the pandemic
an award-winning food blogger from
phoenix arizona has made it her mission
to help restaurants in her area
to avoid a part of excuse me to avoid
being part of that statistic
diana brandt aka azfooty
made headlines after she launched a
fundraiser to help give back to
struggling restaurants and food vendors
and
she's been using the funds she raised to
leave tips
at these restaurants sometimes as much
as a
thousand dollars so please welcome diana
to the show
i love the way that you are handling
wanting to give back i find it so unique
so impressionable uh so actionable
you're just dropping giant
tips yes so i have this platform called
easy foodie on instagram and what i
started doing especially when
covet hit was i just the connections
that i built in the community and the
family
and the support i saw how
they were suffering and how they were
struggling
um so many of my friends were scared to
lose these businesses that they had
built up over the last you know
seven years and i felt like i needed to
do something and so initially when covet
hits
i started selling t-shirts and then we
also did a raffle
and we ended up raising 46 000
for 32 local restaurants
and that money was used to help pay
their employees
keep the lights on all that kind of
stuff um
and so each week we're able to go out
and give these tips that are you know a
thousand dollars
and really just shock and surprise them
and actually i believe the money goes to
the entire restaurant is that correct
yes it goes to the entire restaurant if
they have a couple employees there
that might happen as well um the other
day we gave
to a restaurant called rodura and
the owner was there and we gave it to
her and she was just
in so much shock and just so happy
because
those tips were gonna go to her
employees
who aren't making the same amount of
tips
and so they're struggling to pay their
bills she was like hey this
this money is going to help my employee
pay their rent
this month and um being so close to it
it's a very emotional experience to do
diana wow really
i have so much uh admiration
and respect for everything you're doing
when we had heard
about what you had done at
the restaurant you just mentioned
verdura
uh it's funny because i invited julia
here
i can't believe you were talking about
it i i was like
i julia hi
[Music]
thank you so much for having us we
appreciate you
so immensely and everything that you're
doing resonated with us so much and
you know we appreciate it from the
bottom of our hearts thank you diana and
thank you drew
see surprise diana by the way nobody
nobody mess with julia or you're gonna
get it
hello gentlemen thank you for being with
us today
and verdura is um uh
spanish for vegetable and you're a vegan
restaurant
correct yeah so we're 100 vegan um
located in uptown phoenix we've been
through the wringer in terms of hovid
closed three times now and
thank you to diana's generosity for
really showing our staff
how important it means for us to stay in
business and most importantly show them
appreciation
well i just you know our friends at the
uh plant-based company
field roast wanted to join in
on the tipping too because diana has
inspired
all of us including them and we would
love to leave
a five thousand dollar tip at your
restaurant
and
thank you so much well it's so fitting
because field roast
is a plant-based meat and cheese company
who's committed to bringing bold flavor
to your plates at home and restaurants
across the country
and diana how you're able to raise these
funds and the way you're giving them
you're such an inspiration and you
really blew our minds so
thank you for allowing us in on the
party
and um you know thank you to field roast
and diana
and julia and the gentleman don't mess
with julia
and um for more information on how you
can support diana's initiative
i say this with like fingers pointing
because i'm so passionate about it visit
our website please
and um we would love to eat at your
restaurant as soon as it's safe and
possible
we celebrate you julia and diana
and you know gentlemen thank you thank
you so much
for being on the show today